recently tesla stock has skyrocketed
as more and more investors start to
recognize the long-term growth potential
of tesla however apple and
google actually recognized this
potential seven years ago
when they both tried to buy out tesla
but clearly
these deals did not go through so why
did the deals fall through
and what may have happened if apple or
google succeeded
in acquiring tesla
well starting off 2013 was a high growth
year for tesla
just like this year they started the
year off at just 35
a share and skyrocketed peaking at 193
a share of course this was before the
recent five to one stock split
meaning that in today's share prices
tesla started 2013
at seven dollars and grew to and 60
cents
as a result apple's bid of 240
a share or 48 today was not a low ball
offer by any means
in fact it respected the recent 5x run
up
and even offered 20 to 25 more
the long-term investors would obviously
not be happy with this buyout
as they likely didn't want to sell out
for a 20
premium nonetheless the offer itself
was quite fair but then why did the deal
not go through
well apple had one fatal contingency
with their offer
apple insisted that elon musk had to
step away
from day-to-day operations and that
obviously was not going to work with
elon musk
but it wasn't just apple who tried to
buy tesla
google also considered buying the
electric car manufacturer
earlier that year before the run up in
march of 2013
elon musk met with google co-founder and
then ceo
larry page elon musk was looking for
google to buy tesla
for six billion dollars in cash along
with the commitment to invest
five billion into building factories as
needed this comes out to a per share
price
of about 32 dollars so quite a bit lower
than the offer from apple
but this was before the run up as for
the 5 billion dollar factory investment
we can't include this into the purchase
price as apple would have more than
likely
funded such ventures as well the deal
with google
also included a contingency that elon
musk could continue running the company
for at least 8 more years or until the
model 3 was released
larry page didn't mind elon running the
company
and we know that google has been very
interested in the car space
for over a decade now so google
didn't really have any objections to the
deal at this point
tesla only had enough money to sustain
their losses for two more weeks
so the situation was quite critical
however
the potential for a deal quickly died
out after the first quarter of 2013
when tesla was able to squeeze out its
very first profit in history
it wasn't a very big profit as it
clocked in
at just 11 million dollars however
this was enough to boost investor
confidence and the 2013
run up which enabled tesla to pay down
their excessive loan balance
making them no longer a bankruptcy risk
considering this
it's no wonder why tesla rejected
apple's offer
later that year today we know that tesla
came out all right even though they're
still not strongly profitable
they are at the very least sustainable
but
this wasn't always the case as tesla
came quite close to bankruptcy
in 2018 as well after the model 3
production ramp
so what would have happened instead if
the deal with apple
actually went through and apple bought
tesla in 2013
well the companies are not all that
different in terms of their customer
base
both apple and tesla have raging fans
that cheer on every product release and
fill up their pre-order books within
days
similarly both tesla and apple have
quite similar design language focusing
on minimalism
and function however the first glaring
difference between the two companies
is quality control tesla has struggled
with quality control
for years at this point you'll often
find unpainted sections of the car
and sometimes even find disconnected
rear seats
this was even the case with the recent
model y
apple has also had their own share of
quality control issues
with bent ipad chassis and unreliable
macbook keyboards
but apple is by no means infamous for
quality control issues
like tesla and thus this would be one of
the first issues they address
but how do you accomplish this well the
straightforward answer would be scaling
down production
and apple would have no problems killing
down tesla
and they probably wouldn't even release
the model 3
at least not at 35 000 the thing is
apple has never cared about market share
or
beating competitors in terms of market
share as steve jobs has said
our goal is to make the best personal
computers in the world and make
products we are proud to sell and would
recommend to our family and friends
and i think we'd all agree that
disconnected rear seats
are not something to be proud of tim
cook recently reaffirmed that apple
still believes in this notion our goal
is the best
not the most consequently apple doesn't
have a dominant position
in any of the marketplaces or sectors in
which they conduct business
considering this it's pretty safe to
assume that they wouldn't change this
philosophy
when it comes to running tesla elon musk
has run tesla
in the hopes of accelerating the global
transition into sustainable energy
apple on the other hand would have
turned tesla into a highly profitable
niche player
in this reality the model s would have
likely been their main product
indefinitely they likely would have
eventually come out with the model 3
but it would likely come in at around
fifty thousand dollars
also they wouldn't pitch the car very
hard
the model three would have likely been
treated like the iphone 5c
or the recent iphone sc meanwhile
they would push towards coming out with
a more futuristic model s
and roadster and this would be where
most of their efforts lay
aside from this apple is very involved
in the software side
so they would no doubt push forward on
the autonomy side
as well however they would likely not
release all of these beta updates
and test software like tesla does they
wouldn't release each feature
until the feature is basically flawless
after all
one of apple's most famous mottos is it
just
works with that being said we would
likely see a much more relaxed time
frame for full self driving
and we wouldn't see any autonomous
capability
until it was perfect apple does have a
lot of money
so it's not like they would be in any
rush to push out such software
or any vehicle models anyways on the
bright side
tesla likely would have never been in
danger of bankruptcy
as apple would just endlessly fund them
as long as they still believe in the
company's future
so that's likely the path we would have
seen apple take with
tesla however despite the deal not going
through
apple did not give up on the automotive
space
right after the deal fell through apple
started working on project titan
in 2014 with upwards of 1000 employees
the goal of the project was originally
to develop an ev
however it seems like they have since
transitioned into just
focusing on autonomous driving software
despite this
many analysts still believe that apple
will come out with their own electric
vehicle
between 2023 and 2025
so we'll just have to wait and see and
ask for if tesla went with
google well google is no stranger to
running unprofitable companies
most of their services are wildly
unprofitable
including youtube which has bled
billions during its lifetime
unlike apple google's plan is to offer
as
many services and products for no profit
or even a loss in order to get as many
people
as possible onto the google ecosystem
at this point they profit from people
using their main service
google.com as a result if google had
bought tesla
we would likely see google go along with
tesla's plan
to consistently launch cheaper and
cheaper cars
using knowledge and profits from their
previous vehicles
on top of this google has some of the
best software
and artificial intelligence engineers in
the world just like
apple thus google would likely transfer
a solid portion of their it team
to work on full self driving and with
google's vast resources and similar
vision
tesla would have likely been able to
pump out fully self-driving cars
as well as cheaper electric cars even
sooner
as this didn't happen however google has
just stuck to their own autonomous car
company
waymo but really at the end of the day
aside from the hiccup in 2018 tesla has
been progressing quite rapidly
anyways so it wasn't that big of a deal
that they didn't complete a deal with
one of the tech giants
for apple and google however being able
to add tesla
into their portfolio would have been
quite beneficial
as it would have likely added hundreds
of billions onto their already monster
market caps
nonetheless google and apple are doing
better than ever before as well
so i don't think they're really
complaining about it either
do you guys think tesla would have been
better off or worse off
if apple or google had acquired them
comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys think tesla
is just getting started
and of course consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one